ohibò quanti complimenti per il video
sono contempo veramente però grazie
mille per per il supporto dal mio
ritorno perché un po che devo di essere
morto
virtualmente a livello di di visual di
youtube di numeri invece ne avete
stupito e bianchi è piaciuto sono
veramente contento che sono successe
svariate cose dall'uscita di quel video
lì per esempio nel lewis ci ha fatto
sapere che lui non fa parte del network
del management di fede
infatti io non mi sono usato dirlo
perché non ero sicura e quindi grazie
per aver chiarito poi ha risposto la
dolcissima matilde de angelis
rifiutandomi è in dio scherzavo quindi
ho ricevuto un rifiuto vero da una
proposta fin da questa questa è la mia
vita è inoltre uno dei commenti che più
mi è arrivato sotto il video è il motivo
per il quale io mi sia tagliato i
capelli e molti hanno risposto a questa
cosa qui per assomigliare a salvini e io
quindi oggi mi sono
grazie mille attrezzato con la cravatta
verde padania quindi si sono siamo a
posto e oggi però abbiamo il nostro
primo ospite
probabilmente alcuni di voi se lo
ricorderanno per l'interpretazione
magistrale in che in terapie ha fatto
anche altre cose non mi ricordo
inizialmente l'idea era quella di non
invitare gli altri youtubers perché
sarebbe troppo facile e poi sembrerebbe
più una una collaborazione più che altro
però con lui voglio fare un'eccezione
perché è gratuito e vi fa fare un botto
di news
signore e signori lorenzo studi in arte
dj
[Musica]
quanto fa cagare in mano tutto tu sarai
abituato ad avere tutta la gente dietro
le telecamere
sì però dipende dallo show in questione
ad esempio io ho fatto cattelan è nemica
molto sotto perché porca miseria resi
però ti dico che fa il suo effetto
essere qui in questa torino quanto ai
cattelan da 1 a 10 questo show 0,5 ma
perché manca qualcosa a proposito di
cattelan perché io mi ricordo la tua la
tua serata da cartella che io quando sia
stato invitato da lui dai pcc
io ho detto porca miseria finalmente
finalmente hanno capito cosa devono far
vedere anche se è un dato da cattelan e
ti ha fatto fa lo dici tu cosa ti ha
fatto fa mi ha fatto fare la chumby
valli challenge
era bello vedere un connubio tra il web
e la televisione invece hanno l'hanno
fatto diventare voluti solo web proprio
perché in quel momento e cell andava di
moda charlie magni
[Musica]
secondo te nel periodo di youtube in cui
siamo diciamo dall'inizio del 2018
il gameplay stanno effettivamente
iniziando leggermente a calare o essere
assolutamente sì è un problema perché la
moda cambia sempre poi più che gameplay
adesso ad esempio entra subentrato four
nights che va beh spacca i cui abbiamo
visto sul web ormai veramente cambia
tutto quindi se ci dobbiamo rinnovare di
brutto tutti e io stesso se ne trovò 100
cose che non avrei mai fatto prima
fate che io avro una mia troupe libro io
tra l'altro l'unica cosa che ho notato
questo negli ultimi tre anni e che
quando facevo un video particolare che
esplodeva di views e poi per due o tre
mesi
vivevo
di rendita comunque il video ma non che
quel video mi faceva virus per coprire
tutte le altre che la gente mi dice
diceva fa vj che ha fatto e eaters in
italia e quindi guardiamo il video di
oggi che sexy seconds
invece se tu non fai un video che
esplode per un anno non fai niente
quindi magari energie intorno un
contenuto solo però lo devi fare e io
avessi a terni non vendete non l'ho
fatto
papini era un anno che sono così ma io
so che tu e mi sembra email
avete fatto tempo fa qualcuno qualcosa
non è sicuro non è chiaro è una specie
di blog mentari già dopo il lungo fatto
molto più professionale di un blog dove
una troupe ci ha seguiti per vedere come
insomma lavoriamo dietro le quinte ci ha
seguiti in giappone per vedere come blog
chiamo e uscirà tra un po su sky ci
dobbiamo pagare in mano lorenzo no
perché non c'è nessun copione quindi va
benissimo
questo è di ci sia mi stai dicendo
qualcosa lorenzo già parlare di sé non
ti sto dicendo ne vuoi già parlare di
chi non ci sia dice che abbiamo già
parlato diventerà più adesso adesso io
voglio che buona quest'acqua molto voi
ce l'ho ancora un pochino non avevano
mai parlato l'agente ha sempre creduto
che a me fosse piaciuto l'inter davvero
sì perché ha detto non ne parla perché
suo amico lorenzo da sia il mio amico
lorenzo ma voglio sentir la tua opinione
degli in terapia da attore la mia la mia
opinione diventerà p
allora innanzitutto non sono critico
cinematografico quindi io non riesco a
non riesco a trovare le principali
pecche del film però quella che ho
notato io da spettatore medio è che non
c'è una trama fino all'ottanta per cento
del film ricordiamo anche questo è
l'unica pezzo di recensione che posso
fare a dopo anni e che il film si
conclude con voi voi che batte il nemico
il problema è che viene battuto per un
errore di montano già sembrava dettagli
l'ha detto anche victor l'altro questa
cosa si diceva che ci siamo parlati
c'era anche zona vero c'è anche zona che
si chiamava come si chiamava san filippo
è bellissimo perché io non sono sono
stato bulli dato nel film sia stato
utilizzato da gianfilippo e chi è che
non è mai stato così calda jean film i
giuda proprio la faccia da sanfilippo
assolutamente è stata una bella
esperienza perché ti insegna a lavorare
in gruppo ma ho capito che sono fatto
per lavorare non in gruppo per capire di
non essere di non essere che hanno
ragione alla fan cinema milano aveva una
gavetta ho preso una cosa in sei tu sei
tu anche tra i due
se vuoi mettere
però io ho visto nel tuo instagram su
facebook eccetera che tu hai fatto la
foto con una marea di vip e ne ha
incontrati in un sacco nelle tue
peripezie i tuoi eventi eccetera
eccetera quindi io vorrei che mi parla
sui fondi
io tirerò fuori delle foto vorrei che mi
parlava già ora di colore asilo e mio
zio il mio zio paolo è stato già allora
era pieno di gente quindi tu hai la tua
chance in due secondi ed è andata così
ciao ciao
e lui se ne va non aveva scattato la
foto e gli faccio non è lui
please è tornato indietro ha fatto
questa faccia qui e io ho fatto il video
e poi o screenato il video per essersi
quello di registrare di avere la
spigolosità la faccia esatto previdi tu
sei uno di quelli che non fa la foto e
torna dopo gli strali non mi disse
eliminato chi lo fa non l'ho scritto io
ti chiesi se ci avesse mai fermato
qualche vip per fare la foto e quindi
tiro fuori questa sfida nessun senso
davvero erano mi ero da fiumicino
all'aeroporto di fiumicino e c'era gigi
che era sul seduto su un col telefono mi
hanno fermato dei fan nel mentre che io
chiedevo la foto a lui
e allora quando è successo lui si è
alzato ha detto a famosi del suo ragazzo
e ha fatto la foto e la messa su questa
foto non è sul mio visto che sul suo
instagram
quindi se tu scrolli ne facilita e se
sono io
un traguardo che nella vita è
effettivamente una cosa molto bella poi
questa foto fa parte anche delle tue
passioni
almeno questa sì lui è martin garics
l'ho conosciuto la prima volta nel 2017
dell'acqua monza in italia in quella
stanza c'eravamo io fedez martin garics
e basta io entrò nella stanza e telo
giuste lo giuro su dio la prima cosa che
ho sentito è stata martin garics appena
entro lui che diceva 130 in un italiano
senza giunta da questo possiamo dedurre
che felici ha chiesto scusa puoi dirmi
103 gli ha dato quello che poi l'ha
anche detto sappa è stato bellissimo
il proposito dei concerti di martin
garics stiamo intervallando gente
worldwide ad albano e gigi d'alessio e
lui era era lo stesso giorno vedi che
sono vestite uguali
dai concerti di martin gari quindi al
bano era il concerto di martin e non so
neanche come dirlo sembra veramente così
ma ce lo fosse per la figlia che
immagino di sì però un duetto tra c'è
una colla brama harting ariccia albano
dopo quella di gabry perché anche capri
ponte ha fatto un pezzo con al bano
poi l'ultima così rispondiamo la domanda
prima allora questi siamo io e te quanto
tempo fa 2003 noi 12 così sono io ma
questo sito questo è anche un po lucio
battisti ma sei anche tu questo qui è
che io non è che sia in grado finita
mamma mia
ero sola volta l'altro questa foto lei
stampata dal mio instagram con un
effetto orribile che io ho messo alla
foto che vedete lo hanno addirittura
davanti all'obiettivo
tu c'è stato quando è stato l'anno
scorso due anni fa anche avevi tutti
contro di te
era bellissimo su dipiù di più break si
è da due anni che non sento di nulla non
so cosa è successo
e io ti ho sempre detto se io ma anche
altre persone che conosco fossimo stati
nelle tournée nelle tue scarpe ci si io
abito al nono piano mi sarei buttato giù
dal balcone e l'avrei fatta
immediatamente finita io sono una
persona che se legge un commento su
internet sia positivo che negativo su
una persona che non si fa tanto
influenzare perché quella persona non la
conosco direttamente io sono giudice di
me stesso quindi io so se sto sbagliando
meno e ci sono volte in cui ho sbagliato
a volte in cui non ho sbagliato quando è
stata la volta che hai sbagliato di più
nella mia carriera l'ho sbagliato
diverse uno dei primissimi placement che
ho fatto è un placement su una compagnia
telefonica è praticamente io mi ero
fatto una foto con lo sfondo di questa
compagnia telefonica
sullo sfondo nome lo ricordino che
casino avevi fatto anche la crisi motore
di fare questo perché ho detto poi la
gente dice che sono un venduto perché i
primissimi tempi mi importava
e allora 8 scritto nei commenti e un
file mi ha fatto una foto a caso kant
errore adesso
si è quindi cielo si di borsato pensavo
tirarsi fuori l'album di figurine
no no non è quello romano a lei l'aveva
di no tanto parlare di queste cose qui
ma tu sei contento di aver fatto queste
cose qua c'è non te lo sto chiedendo in
modo accusatorio non lo sapeva in questo
in realtà è un buon passo passo avanti
abbastanza importante perché le aziende
difficilmente accettano sun
sono youtuber di non pubblicare la sua
faccia ma il suo brand in questo caso
qua c'è il mio brand il tuo breve quindi
questa è questo è un traguardo molto
importante ed è una differenza enorme
che la gente spesso lo bene no certo
perché qua avendo messo il mio logo
eccetera fai capire che la potenza del
tuo brand è importante tanto quanto il
tuo la tua persona cosa che all'inizio
non c'era
ce ne sono domande che nessuno di è
molto meglio diventano tiro fuori tutta
una setta c'è anche la cartellina questa
non la vedeva dagli anni 80 più o meno
sì la usano ancora la cartelli ma sì che
una delle cose più prese mancini briscoe
io la uso per metterci documenti di
lavoro
pensa che vigore l'attore non come stato
triste per la tua cartellina con la tua
fa però la uso per questo io vorrei a
questo era il periodo in cui invece ed
andava di moda la faccia non non il
brand vorrei aprire con te una bustina
di figurine per lei trovate chiuse e me
l'hanno regalato e tortuoso gentili che
voleva vedere e capire come sa se
troviamo il gold aspetto è stata dico ai
tempi c'era la possibilità di trovare
qua dentro la tesserina d'oro tipo
quelli uomo adesso non so se vi è una
giornata con me hanno vinto ha vinto
non so se ce ne sono dentro lorenzo e
quella contro il face e quindi io volevo
solo farti un regalo prima di chiudere
vuole mai le pagine no no no siccome
sono visibili grazie adesivi con la tua
faccia guarda che splendore
così poi a puglia che hanno la tua
scrivani l'idea era quella di farti un
preservativo con la tua fa qua e là
sarebbe veramente difficile perché
almeno perché così puoi prendere target
più ampi ma si è allungata se tu se
perche so che cosa dire non so neanche
cosa lì ma tu hai dato poi arriva
bisognerà dire allora ti ho portato qui
a zappare perché volevo sapere una cosa
sola se quando tutto questo finirà
lorenzo si che sarà domani fra due anni
dieci anni a parte tutti si è fatto un
idea di quando potrebbero finire tutto
uguale in realtà no non mi sono mai
siamo qui abita cambia poco rotto e
abbastanza soldi da fregartene il cane
solo cazzo me ne frega a me sapere
questo io gli ho già sotterrati in
giardino non lo so cosa andremo a fare o
cosa farai tu ma che cosa penso che lo
sai già
e io mi ammazzo cosa puoi fare quando
finisci artisticamente di fare youtube
la mutanda volata menica penso ho
iniziato alle live per questo pensavo di
fare una roba del genere ma non lo so
perché buona domenica su in radio no è
scattato l'allarme di mannaia a livello
finanziario tu sei a posto però non
preserva sarai a posto per due di loro
però davvero dai che secondo me secondo
te per quanto senza dire una cifra per
quanto tempo sei a posto che si alza
pagava sei che una bellissima domanda
efisio non lo so v 40 anni di unione
aveva 60 muoiono in realtà non ne ho
idea quella questa la verità che non ne
oro si tengono non mi sono mai fatto
questo contesto vado a casa me lo faccio
perché mi metto minime sono ascrivibili
mamma mia
pratico ci aveva azzeccato sindaco
tu hai fatto riaccenderà telecamera si
poveracci perché se ne fece né e non
volevo correggetemi adesso corregge non
ho detto in radio the thin light
sbagliare non voglio correggere ma tuffa
youtube da più tempo di me hai sempre
ragione
l'addio ultimo a zappare perché comunque
uno sbocco futuro potrebbe sicuramente
virgin